today I'm doing a two-part experiment
involving a spool I've wrapped some
nylon rope around the spool and right
now it's coming over the top as you can
see I'm gonna place the spool down
beside me and I'm gonna pull the rope
horizontally towards me and I want you
to make a prediction what's gonna happen
when I pull the rope will it move to the
right or to the left or it does it
depend on how I pull the rope
it'll goes to the left I don't know why
I think it'll go to the right
what are you ready what do you reckon if
it's loose
yeah it's just gonna spin around on the
hook on the blue bit but if you if it's
tight it's it's gonna go to what no it's
gonna stay where it is it's gonna unwind
I'd like you to make your prediction now
by clicking on one of the annotations
now I should point out that this is only
the first part of the experiment so try
not to overthink it if you're on a
mobile device you can find the links in
the description below all right are you
ready three two one
[Applause]